well let's start with the colts titans
game we have something else to get to
this segment but let's begin with the
fact that there's a game tonight and
it's a good thursday night game it is
and it's a game that that
all of a sudden
is
significant because the titans have
stumbled a bit in recent weeks the cults
are just kind of hanging in there
they've got this jekyll and hyde
mentality this year one week they're
good one week they're not you think
they're rounding the corner and then
they get smacked down
titans and colts playing for de facto
mid-season first place in the afc south
in tennessee they face each other twice
in 17 days i never like that i don't
like to space it out it's it's colts
raven's cults for the titans over the
next three weeks i'd rather those games
those twice a year games be spread out
more what do you think about that as a
preliminary observation on this game
that we're going to see this game twice
in the next two and a half weeks you
know i i get it you're right i mean
especially when it's a you know a big
division matchup you'd like to see it a
little bit more spread out but the one
thing i'll say just in my experience
and even talking to you know other
people that have played in the nfl
the game when it is played that close to
each other two games and you know like
you said 17 days or whatever
it it becomes more personal that's the
one thing i will say because it's still
fresh in your mind some of the things
maybe the trash talking personal stuff
that they might have said to you on the
field you still remember that you could
still remember the feeling of the win or
the loss you know you know you know in
in particular the team that loses you
still really feel that 17 days later
and so i do think it adds a little bit
of a chippiness to the match-up would be
my overall take there i don't know if
it's necessarily the best yeah for fans
and things like that but i do think it's
a little bit more personal and will add
to a legitimate more hate the next time
around when they play and i think that's
the thing i look at sometimes when i see
those games close together
yeah i i don't disagree with that and
it's it's a i still would prefer i
prefer i can spread out it seems like
it's a dynamic that has popped up
recently i mean teams have been doing
the twice per year thing
forever as far as the nfl is concerned
at least back until the merger that's
been part of the characteristics of
being in a division you play all your
division rivals twice but it just seems
like in recent years there have been
more of these packet together two weeks
apart uh games it does that it happened
several times this year yeah it's
happening several times this year but it
will happen starting tonight with the
colts and the titans and
i
look we're going to do our mega pix
podcast later today i think we're both
going to probably pick the titans in
this one just because they've shown us
more consistency this season with the
colts
uh what's been your overall assessment
though halfway through the season of
this experiment that the indianapolis
colts have hatched with
one year
maybe
maybe two yeah they went into it
thinking one year with philip rivers and
then a quarterback they can build around
come 2021. what do you think of rivers
in the cult so far well yeah i think
it's just been good but nothing more
than that just you know a solid good not
great not wow you know it's not bad or
in the middle of the road hey listen for
the most part they've beaten the teams
they should they should beat
um they have a
a elite unit on their football team as
far as their defense is concerned i mean
it really is it's it's it's a big time
defense it really is super bowl caliber
that way
but as far as the offense i think that's
kind of been the letdown of the
indianapolis colts there's no i mean
there's no doubt about that i don't have
to think there's no doubt hey we talk
about the blue wall right the offensive
line all those things they haven't been
as impressive the run game hasn't really
been there you know they've had some
injuries at receiver that i think we've
all
maybe just swiped under the rug a little
bit and haven't really maybe given it
the notice it deserves you know no t.y
hilton no paris campbell michael pittman
jr just got back in the lineup last week
so for me too the pass offense has been
a hair underwhelming let alone you know
rivers in in the losses has had some bad
turnovers and some bad moments i think
that's the one thing you could take away
from all three losses last week it was a
little unlucky the browns and jaguars
games he did some dumb stuff like some
phillip rivers what the hell are you
doing in the fourth quarter chargers
type of stuff so i think that's really
the big thing and that's where i
probably look at it mike when you say
two years with philip rivers i think
we're in a critical part right now
where they're going okay it's been good
yeah we've been a little injured
but it hasn't been like whoa you know
knock our socks off and we're definitely
in this for two years i'd be shocked for
that i think he's still playing for
another crack to be the quarterback of
this team next year and we're going to
see how that plays out tonight and here
in the rest of the year
yeah he has expressed interest in being
with the cults for two seasons but a lot
of it depends upon what they do the rest
of the way do they make the playoffs if
they win the division then maybe it
becomes a no-brainer but it's all to be
determined you mentioned ty hilton he's
due to return tonight that'll be another
guy who has been
kind of confusing
this year for the colts jonathan taylor
yeah second-round draft pick who
inherited the starting job when marlon
mack suffered a torn achilles tendon
weak one against the jacksonville
jaguars right out of the gates against
the vikings 101 rushing yards for
jonathan taylor in his first game as a
starter but he's tailed off since then
he had six carries for 27 yards against
the ravens and he had the fumble that
chuck clark scooped up and jumped over
philip rivers in return for a touchdown
that was the turning point really in the
loss to the ravens last week frank reich
said that the team still has confidence
in jonathan taylor do you uh i do it
hasn't looked as good as what i would
have expected coming out of wisconsin
i'm still looking at a young runner that
i think is
thinking too much
just not reacting and playing football
and that can happen you know as a rookie
it happens a lot that's why sometimes we
see those rookies where we go yeah it
was a so-so rookie year and all of a
sudden that second year we go whoa this
guy looks different this year you know
and i think jonathan you know jonathan
taylor yeah it's not no pedal to the
metal that's what i'm missing mike you
know we talk about that sometimes with
running backs guys who just hit the hole
with abandon okay i'm gonna go a million
miles per hour and then i'll figure out
where to go as i approach the hole he's
a little bit more tentative right now
and you know between that yeah fumble
you know he has he's always had ball
security issues but i think the the more
the more disappointing thing too is this
you know the offensive line and and that
lack of domination there that was a unit
where i looked at and went i think
that's a top unit in all of football and
it's up there close to that but i don't
know if it's like top three or four this
year pass protection wise certainly run
game when i watch them lately i just go
it's good but it's not as dominant as
i've seen the last two years maybe out
of them in that position
jordan wilkins has seen his workload
increase in recent weeks taylor played
13 fewer snaps than wilkins in the win
over the lions and wilkins had more
touches
than taylor last week reich said there
was never a discussion during the game
let's let the other guys get in there we
have confidence in taylor all the
confidence in the world of course you
kind of have to say that you're not
gonna you're not going to say publicly
at this point that you don't have
confidence in the guy unless you're
bruce erians i guess yeah but
privately jonathan taylor's probably
getting the message that he needs to
hold on to the football was his first
fumble of the year at least he had no
fumbles through the first seven games
there may have been one against the
lions but definitely one against the
ravens and uh that that's that's an
issue especially tonight when you can't
afford to be giving the titans any extra
possessions now the titans
they've lost some of their luster they
lost two in a row the loss to the
bengals was a head scratcher and then
it looked like they were in the process
of obliterating the bears but the bears
kind of put some things together late
that that almost allowed the bears to
cover the six-point spread chris well
yeah i mean the titans you know it was a
good win for them last night last week
it was a struggle on offense because
that bears you know defense is really
really good
but
you know as far as
uh their own defense hey there's still
work to be done now they caused some
turnovers and did things like that last
week and you know started to play
prevent defense but there's a lot of
questions about that tennessee titans
defense there really is across the board
i mean their inability to really stop
big pass plays has been an issue you
know by any team that can really throw
the football has picked them apart to a
degree and we've talked about it you
know lack of a pass rush is a real real
big issue
it is and that's compromised mike vrabel
a lot to i don't know what to do blitz
play coverage how do i approach this
he's trying it all he really is um they
just don't have that
type of guy as far as an edge rusher
that could disrupt that way
and
uh yeah they've been burned a lot you
know and and i expect this tonight to be
a struggle for them to stop the colts
passing offense i think the colts and
what they do is going to give them a
tough time this tennessee titans defense
is certainly nothing special in the past
game that's for sure
it really is amazing to think that that
they've struggled as much as they have
with that pass rush to davey and clowny
off the injury report there's been talk
about possibly needing surgery on the
knee uh but but he did fully participate
in practice tuesday and wednesday he's
got a knee and an illness but he's good
to go for tonight they and and i i agree
with you that he's more than just a guy
who gets sex he's a guy who disrupts the
play but he's not doing enough
disruption this year to let his
teammates get to the quarterback no
period you're right you know last year
we didn't care about the stats right
when he was playing for seattle we kept
going doesn't matter he's the most
disruptive guy on their defense he's the
best player in their front seven he was
the best player in their defense it
didn't matter you know this year that is
it's not the case first off the best
player on the tennessee titans defense
is jeffrey simmons which was a great
pick by greg robinson and vrabel and two
drafts ago i mean he's he is that guy
john robinson i'm john robinson sorry
called him greg uh but yeah yeah but uh
he's he's the the alpha disrupter the
guy that teams have to game plan and
worry about clowning has been very
spotty there's been some games where you
go damn there's to davey uncle he's he's
around and disrupting but there's been a
few other games where you just go is he
out here is he doing anything what is he
doing and i think that always goes back
into the the thing we've always talked
about him mike it's just the knee issue
is a real issue not being able to
practice not always having to be not
always being able to play at 100 playing
at 85 percent you just don't know what
you're gonna get and when you're gonna
get you know the best joe deviant
clownie he has to offer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports